N
LOS ANGELES.
THANK YOU.
RUSSIAN TROOPS CONTINUE INTENSE
SHELLING ATTACKS IN UKRAINE.
LET'S BRING IN SOUTH CAROLINA
CONGRESSMAN RALPH NORMAN FOR
MILITARY OPERATIONS IN THE
HUMANITARIAN CRISIS.
HE IS ON THE HOUSE HOMELAND
SECURITY AND OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE.
CONGRESSMAN, FIRST OF ALL THE
CONTINUING QUANDARY OF THE
POLISH MEN, SOVIET BUILT
FIGHTERS THAT BELONG TO POLAND
THAT THE UNITED STATES FIRST
SAID YOU CAN SHIP THOSE INTO
UKRAINE AND BACK AWAY.
WHERE DOES THAT STAND AND WHAT
DO YOU THINK ABOUT THE STALEMATE
THAT THE UNITED STATES HAS LEFT
POLAND.
>> IT IS UNFORTUNATE THAT THIS
PRESIDENT IS CONTINUING TO NOT
GET THE GREEN LIGHT AND TO GIVE
THE UKRAINIANS WHAT THEY NEED TO
FIGHT.
IT'S NOT LIKE WERE ASKING
AMERICANS HOW TO FIGHT, IT IS
GIVING THE UKRAINIAN PEOPLE THE
NECESSARY PROTECTION AND WHY HE
IS NOT LETTING THEM USE OUR
OFFRAMP TO FLY IN IS BEYOND ME.
NOBODY CAN UNDERSTAND WHAT HE IS
DOING NOW.
JON: I WOULD A PLACE OF THE
DEMOCRATIC SENATOR DURBIN THE
MAJORITY WHIP HAD TO SAY ABOUT
THIS.
I'LL GET YOUR THOUGHTS
AFTERWARDS.
>> WERE ASKING FOR ONE THIRD OF
THE POLISH AIR FORCE TO BE SENT
INTO UKRAINE, THE PEOPLE OF
POLAND WANT TO MAKE CERTAIN THAT
THEY ARE SAFE.
THERE ARE OTHER WAYS TO PROVIDE
AIR MISSILES AND AIR DEFENSE
THAT WILL KEEP THE RUSSIANS AT
BAY IN TERMS OF AERIAL ATTACK.
I THINK THERE ARE WAYS TO DO IT
THAT ARE CONSISTENT WITH THE
NATO ALLIANCE AND WOULD NOT
JEOPARDIZE EXPANDING THIS INTO
WORLD WAR III.
>> THE PEOPLE POLAND WANT TO
KNOW THAT THEY ARE SAFE BUT THEY
ARE ALSO COVERED UNDER THE NATO
TREATY AND ATTACK ON POLAND
WOULD BRING THE FIRE OF NATO
DOWN ON THE RUSSIANS WERE
ANYBODY ELSE WHO STAGES AN
ATTACK.
WHY NOT SEND THEM OVER?
>> THE PRESIDENT IS SENDING THE
MESSAGE TO THE WHOLE WORLD HE IS
NOT GOING TO DO IT.
TIME IS RUNNING OUT YOU LOOK AT
WHAT'S HAPPENING TO THE CITIES
ACROSS UKRAINE.
80% OF THE TIME THEY'RE TORN UP
AT THE TIME IS RUNNING OUT HE'S
GETTING MISSED OPPORTUNITY AND I
DON'T THINK HE IS.
HE HAS GIVEN NO INDICATION THAT
HE'S GONNA MAKE THAT CALL WHICH
HE SHOULD MAKE.
>> THE RUSSIANS HAVE SAID
MARIUPOL HAS SOMETHING LIKE SIX
HOURS TO SURRENDER.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENS IF
THEY DON'T.
THERE IS NO INDICATION FROM THE
UKRAINIANS THAT THEY ARE GOING
TO BUT THERE IS VERY LITTLE LEFT
OF MARIUPOL ALREADY.
HERE'S WHAT SENATOR BARRASSO OF
WYOMING HAD TO SAY ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT'S STATURE WITH SEEMS
TO BE LEADING FROM BEHIND.
>> THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN PUSHED
AND PULLED TO WHERE HE IS TODAY.
IT WAS CONGRESS THAT BROUGHT
ABOUT SANCTIONS AND BROUGHT
ABOUT THE BAN ON RUSSIAN OIL,
THE BROUGHT ABOUT WEAPONS AND
ALL OF THE BIG AID PACKAGE THAT
I VOTED FOR A WEEK OR TWO AGO
$13 BILLION.
SO FOR THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
ONLY RELEASED 1 BILLION OF THAT.
IF THEY DUG MORE INTO SANCTIONS
WE MIGHT NOT OF BEEN INTO THIS
IF THEY PUNISH SANCTIONS BEFORE
THE TANKS BEGAN TO ROLL.
JON: PRESIDENT BIDEN SAID THE
SANCTIONS WOULD PREVENT ALL OF
THIS FROM HAPPENING IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
HE WAS OBVIOUSLY WRONG ABOUT
THAT.
WHY NOT RELEASE MORE MONEY AND
GET THE ANTIAIRCRAFT SYSTEMS
INTO UKRAINE.
>> HE IS NOT ABOUT THIS SINCE
IPA OF LAST YEAR, HE TAKE NO
ACTION HE SLOWLY WALKED THE
SANCTIONS FROM RUSSIA AND
EVERYTHING THAT HE IS DOING IS
AS IF HE IS WANTING UKRAINE TO
FALL.
HE IS NOT HELPING HIMSELF OR
LETTING RUSSIANS NEGOTIATE THE
JCPOA WITH IRANIANS.
THE QUESTION IS WHY.
IF THIS IS NOT THE CASE FOR
TAKING SERIOUSLY AND IMPEACHING
BIDEN I GO TO WHAT IS, WE ARE
SEEING ON THE NATIONAL AND WORLD
STAGE A HUMANITARIAN CRISIS LIKE
WE NEVER SEEN BEFORE.
WE SAW THAT WITH ZELENSKYY SPOKE
TO CONGRESS, HE SHOWED CHILDREN
DO NOT BELONG IN THE INNOCENT
CIVILIANS.
IT IS TIME FOR ALL OF CONGRESS
TO COME FORWARD AND ASK BIDEN TO
DO THE RIGHT THI